hier sind sie heiß ersehnt und lange
erwartet es hat ein bisschen gedauert
aber jetzt kommen die lobbys die lage
lage lage ist bei mir jetzt ganz locker
eigentlich nicht ein bisschen müde war
das grad also wenn schon zwei stunden
geschlafen habe aber sonst ist
eigentlich ganz locker wie kommt das
zwei stunde war vorne auf einer
geburtstagsparty und der komfort das war
ein bisschen weniger spannend aber okay
und roman waagrecht jetzt ok und die
lage ist so allgemeinen gut schön aber
auch stressig also wir haben wirklich
viel um die ohren und dann im youtube
und jude oder freunde und also was aber
die lage soll sich ist nochmal gut
stress ok aber was wenn wir es ist das
oder wie empfindet er das selber bei
euch seid ihr habt ihr arbeit weil er so
viel youtube macht seit ihr schüler seid
ihr jugendliche was wäre wie habt ihr
eure rolle oder findet ihr noch eure
rolle oder klar wissen jetzt also wissen
wie sie uns letztlich irgendwie als du
was besonderes wissen halt auch schüler
der noch wir gehen auch noch viel mit
freunden aus oder das was jugendliche
machen und youtube kommt noch dazu
du hast gesagt wieso beruf also das ist
auf jeden fall
es ist ja schon so ein beruf und man ein
bisschen doch schon viel zeit darin aber
es ist nicht so dass wir irgendwie
denken
ja du musst um 6 uhr ausstellung
arbeiten brachte gestern wieder nach
hause es ist natürlich die hobby und
ansonsten eigentlich alles ganz normal
dass man halt im vergleich zu allen
anderen eigentlich gar keine zeit mehr
hat einfach weil man halt noch jede
woche videos auf
das heißt aber ich habe mir gerade hier
bei heiko gehört eine party ist schon
drin
ja aber ihr müsst euch irgendwie
organisiert er euch also wir plan hat
auch wenn wir also wann wir drehen oder
wie wir drehen was wir drehen wenn jetzt
die parodie zum beispiel drin gibt es
viel mehr zeit in anspruch wie wenn
jetzt zum fragen antworten oder wie
klein auf video
so heißt es auch bei uns als drehen weil
das einfach zum beispiel sowie kann auch
videos in zwei stunden gedreht und
parodien nimmt dann schon mindestens ein
drehtag in anspruch und dann kommt noch
als sachen die tonaufnahme oder so dazu
und man macht es halt auch so das war
halt auch immer an gewissen wochenenden
zum beispiel oder wochen halt dann
weniger zu tun hat und dafür dann
bisschen mehr freizeit hat und dann also
das ist halt so ist dass es ausgeglichen
ist und dass jetzt auch zum beispiel
youtube nicht genau das wird oft
vernachlässigt wird aber die freizeit
unser freund oder so auch nicht also das
alles ausgeglichen ist gut beim normalen
jugendlichen neuer alter sind die eltern
tierisch hinterher dass sie überhaupt
ihre hausaufgaben machen
wie kriegt ihr das denn hin schule zu
machen und dann auf youtube dazu sagt
eure mutter ihr friedman video oder ein
macht ihren job macht ihr das ganz
diszipliniert dafür keine hausaufgaben
irgendwie machen video die haben da wird
jetzt nicht so viel zu tun im sinne von
dass wir uns irgendwie sagen was wir
machen sollen also der morgen mit
youtube angefangen da mussten die noch
nicht genau was ist also haben die fans
mitbekommen am anfang an seien sie haben
das dann mitbekommen habe sich auch
gezeigt und
die haben sich dann auch so daran
gewöhnt oder wir haben ein bisschen
erklärt aber in seiner schule also diese
machen ja weiter abu dhabi und die noten
sind okay also jetzt nicht irgendwie
schlimm durchschnitt halt manchmal etwas
besser was schlechter konzert welches
fahrrad masse ist zum beispiel so eine
sache
ansonsten hausaufgaben na ja also ich
setze sich aus und habe ich dem bus
aufgaben aber münster
aber wo es auf gar also hausaufgaben
muss aufgaben deutlich egal hauptsache
man hat sie und ja wir kriegen amri so
viele hausaufgaben auf also wie es bei
dir also normaler so garn und eure
eltern mutter oder eltern müssen euch
nicht ihr kriegt ja selber geregelt also
seid ihr organisierte als andere
jugendliche geben sie eine von
desorganisiert von plan im sinne von
bern fehlte plant ja genau also wir
haben viel zu tun so genau so ist es
also wir haben viel zu tun diese viel
beschäftigt im vergleich zu anderen also
es ist glaub ich auch so dass wir haben
halt noch mehr sachen als andere
jüdische also nicht alle aber damit oft
ein paar sachen mehr zu tun noch
deswegen ist es halt auch schwieriger
ist alles einzuteilen
aber noch mal kurz auf die frage wie den
hausaufgaben und übrigens retten ja die
damals schon macht hausaufgaben macht
fachschule ist er doch wichtig meinte
schule geht hat auch nicht ganz viel
aber auch wie vorher schon gesprochen
hat es ist jedoch wichtig dass er nicht
die schule vernachlässigt wird sondern
das hat auch alles hat alles im
gleichgewicht bleibt das auch wer jetzt
das wird auch nicht jetzt nur noch sechs
schreiben würden nur noch fünf sondern
auch noch relativ gut in der schule sind
weil ich meine man weiß doch nie wie
sich das alles entwickelt
wie kriegt er das denn summer in
anführungszeichen so mental hin weil ihr
unterscheidet euch schon von allen
anderen
oder gibt es andere wege gibt es freunde
die in einer ähnlichen situation sind
diese freunde die vielleicht fußball
fußballer sind
fünf mal die woche trainieren oder sowas
als wir jetzt ja von von dieser misere
aufwand diese videos zu machen und zur
schule zu gehen und privatlebens heute
so wie spielt also wie man gewinnt also
was ist natürlich echt krass und wenn
irgendwie wenn die anderen davon
erzählen die vier wie box zu tun haben
dann fragen die die sich auch wie wir
das überhaupt packen
aber man gewöhnt sich auch dran und man
gewöhnt sich halt da den stress so zu
sagen und man lernt auch damit umzugehen
und weise sicherheit gut einzuplanen man
muss manchmal auch sachen verzichten
können
aber es ist irgendwie das dach dann doch
alles hinzubekommen so zeit nicht also
da man hat halt auch irgendwie probleme
irgendwie das ich habe gesagt man muss
auch das ein und andere verzichten könne
ab und zu aber ansonsten packen wir es
trotzdem irgendwie ich weiß aber dass es
dass sie auf jeden fall viel zu tun
haben und ich weiß selbst nicht wie wir
das packen also irgendwie funktionierte
sultans weil ich weiß wie es geht
ich glaube da hat doch damit was du tun
weil wir halt oft auch nachts drehen und
da kann man am tag halten was für sich
machen oder oder dass wir aber auch
formate hat ja gesagt wo man halt nicht
so weit auch warten braucht wo man paar
stunden dreht irgendwie noch lieber
zloty drehen wir dann irgendwie eine
halbe stunde in der stadt oder auch
video und es hat auch immer was mit den
vor allem mit den privaten zu tun dass
eine video hat mehr aufwand als das
andere und dann kann man sich das auch
so einplanen dass man halt in der woche
wo man jetzt nicht und aufwendiges video
macht wo man mehr zeit hat mehr freizeit
macht man das mit seinen freunden und
dann nehme man sich ein anderes
wochenende wo man sich dann vor dem
treiben jetzt musikvideo dann verzichte
man halt auch seine freizeit auch wenn
video drehen ja auch freizeit ist im
grunde genommen heisst also ich mach das
noch viel wasser
na klar so ist muss auf ihr ist muss auf
jeden fall spaß machen ich finde wenn
die leidenschaft oder
ein video drehen für uns gerne spaß kein
spaß erwarten würde dann wird es auch
nicht mehr viel sinn machen also das ist
auch der grund warum überhaupt
angefangen haben und dass auf jeden fall
wie hat sich das auf euch ausgewirkt auf
eure persönlichkeit
seid ihr schneller erwachsen geworden
oder seid ihr sagen andere leute
vielleicht das ganze zeit hoch es gibt
immer welche die man kannte auch also
auch wenn man auch wenn man die gar
nicht im relax oder so kennt einfach nur
weil man für so viele die auch so ein
bisschen lkw sind oder in unserem alter
decken hat wenngleich arrogant weil wir
halt irgendwie dem alter sind und halte
erfolg auf youtube haben das dann denkt
man gleich mein sei arrogant aber die
meisten kindern halt auch gar nicht mag
deswegen kann man das eine schlecht
beurteilen
die frage aber auch ein arroganter
geworden seid aber erwachsen sein aber
ich glaube wir sind einfach mehr
auffallen dieser online welt und diese
ganze also wisst ihr noch mehr rein
gewachsen
diese online werde ich glaube das ist
doch ganz normal wenn man halt youtuber
ist jetzt mal also das ist bei jedem so
man lernt ja viel mehr dazu und man
lernt neue connect neue leute kennen
es war als beispiel ich hätte oder wir
beide gewinnen so viele leute nicht
kennen wenn es kein youtube geht und so
wenn man wenn man es mal so wenn wir uns
das mal so persönlich sieht also wie wir
zu der beziehung beendet haben oder ich
glaube wir machen sie jetzt schon seit
über zwei jahren
und man wird auf jeden fall auch
selbstbewusst aber man kann auch
irgendwie referaten oder so also
zumindest kommt mir das so vor also ist
auf jeden fall besser referate zu was
halten oder höher voraus wir ganz gut
aber man ist einfach man ist sich
einfach sicherer oder man hat jetzt man
jetzt nicht mehr so aufgeregt und man
kann einfach besser frei reden denn man
ist irgendwie jede woche macht und man
verändert sich im sinne von man wird
halt man wird auf jeden fall
selbstständiger man man lernt halt auch
mit sachen selbstständig zu arbeiten und
auch mit dem stress dem wir haben
umzugehen
also man lernt schon
was dazu weil man das auch letztendlich
benötigt so wenn man zu sagen kann und
erwachsener werden irgendwie früher
erwachsener werden würde ich jetzt nicht
so sagen also pokal an kontur werden wie
man es sieht also dass die handlichkeit
ich glaube es ist jetzt genauso wie du
scheiße jeden samstag
das ist etwas worauf wir bauen jetzt
nicht weniger heiß wie andere
jugendliche in unserem alter ich glaub
mir dass man halten in gewissen
bereichen einfach reifer wird aber das
normal ist zum beispiel gibt es jetzt
auch leute die jetzt so irgendwie
irgendwas anderes machen zum beispiel
ein beispiel irgendwie muss man spielen
hatten
bei der berner so was und dann wird man
wird ja auch reifer zum beispiel in dem
bereich und wenn man halt bereich wie zb
videos man länger ausdrückt oder länger
macht dann hat man halt doch auch immer
mehr dazu und reife kommt damit
erfahrung und das hat halt also in
gewissen bereichen hat ist er damit auch
was zu tun
aber dafür ist in wald dann in anderen
bereichen vielleicht weniger reif also
weniger erwachsenen wie du sagst oder
wie du gefragt hast und so kann man es
ungefähr klären ich habe noch eine gute
frage zum thema arroganz letztlich habe
mich auch mit anderen leuten unterhalten
eben oder junge fußballer die dann schon
ebenso kurz vor der profimannschaft in
dem wird ja oft nachgesagt die gucken
schon so arrogant weil sie eben schon
was da stellen die sind super jung und
sie stellen schon was da was ja bei euch
auch der fall ist aber trotzdem noch mal
nachgehakt führt bei euch nicht so
arrogant der kugel auf die anderen nicht
runter so nach dem motto hall wir haben
youtube kanal
sie hofft zumindest dass es herüber
kommt dann so ist doch gar nicht lernen
wir arbeit nur noch irgendwie mit
kleinen lied über zusammen oder
allgemein also ich sehe mich jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie als etwas besonderes
weil
ist eigentlich so ein mann steht dürfen
was emotionen hat mehr in der
öffentlichkeit und das hat das hat ja
schon was besonderes aber es jetzt nicht
so dass ich mich für was besseres für so
ist es also so hoffe ich auch nicht dass
es über kommen so man muss die kamera
wurde
so hoffe ich hoffe ich dass es so rüber
kommt ich bin viel zu toll und
eingebildet mittels intelligenter ich
will einfach viel zu teuer und
eingebildet zu sein also nochmals also
ob wir was er sonst oder so ich glaube
jeder mensch ist zudem ist in bestimmten
sachen was besonders zum beispiel sin
handwerker zum beispiel ist dem fach
wasser macht zum beispiel handwerk etwas
besonderes mit der unterschied ist dass
man in die auf youtube hat in der alle
öffentlich in der fähigkeit steht und
deshalb einfach mehr leute sehen also
als sie zum beispiel handwerker jetzt
irgendwas handwerk oder werkt hand wird
was anfertigt ja genau was an verleger
handwerks beispiel ist erstmals beispiel
liegt auch ein feedback zum beispiel von
seinen konten ob das jetzt gut ist oder
schlecht und auf youtube sind ist es
halt dann nicht die kunden also doch
schon könnten sozusagen und deshalb die
zuschauer so kannst du dann kann man das
bisschen vergleichen
man ist wenn du wenn man dokument
youtuber ist ist nichts besonderes man
macht ja auch gut ist was man was einem
spaß macht was man vielleicht kann
und da ist nichts besonderes zu machen
100 millionen von menschen machen ist
was besonderes aber man ist jetzt nichts
besseres okay das ist das ist auch der
punkt was ich festgestellt habe beim
fantreffen mit euch
das hat ja auch konsequenzen vielleicht
daher kommt dass die leute mal sagen man
wäre arrogant aber arrogant aber ihr
müsst ja wirklich drauf aufpassen wie
ihr zum beispiel fan treffen mit den
leuten umgeht
ich habe es in köln gesehen waren war
das das war irgendwann in kurzform video
dem paar wochen davor oder was weiß ich
war das nicht
das war im juli ende juli das war mitte
juli das war wirklich das war krass als
umfassende diese zu müssen
wenn man so nett genau sensationell
wir hatten die 300.000 abonnent oder so
und haben deshalb eine woche oder so
davor angekündigt das waren verein
treffen
wir haben nicht nach unseren hauptkanal
angekündigt werden ist nur auf facebook
will unseren zweiten kanal und trotzdem
die haben ein gewitter 30 leuten
gerechnet also gar nicht weil wir das
fast gar nicht angekündigt haben es war
auch so spontan und da war auch andere
youtuber noch dabei und auf einmal waren
da also das war ein paar hundert leute
uns kam das vor auf der domplatte kann
es uns vor wie 5000 deutsche und ist
einfach irre ok 500 auf jeden fall die
hat alle was von dir wollen die stadt
nun nicht rum untermalen namen
geschrieben und du hattest dann keine
security und das hat dann ein bisschen
aus das ist ein bisschen ausgeartet wir
wurden dazu glück abgeholt mit dem auto
von von einem gewissen grad aber es war
auf jeden fall krass und dazu muss man
sagen die security alle sagen ja dann im
security security die ist ja nicht mehr
dürfen nur dafür da um euch an schützen
ihr seid ja noch die man sie am besten
wären sondern sind auch kleine kinder
dabei und die werden dann droht betreut
ist so ist es also passiert und aber
damals keine tore getrieben aber es hat
es auch so wir sehen aber die haben sie
auch schon so wissen gebettet werden
ankommt und das war's schon
das war schon krass also da muss man
schon aufpassen das ist das tollste was
euch in den letzten jahren passiert ist
meint sitzt nur auf youtube bezogen also
alles was damit sich gekommen ist
weil also also es gab also das tollste
ganz sicher aber es gibt schon gewisse
punkte die einfach mega toll waren beim
für mich war zum beispiel der auftritt
beim videodreh mit durchgeht online war
für mich ein mega oder allgemein der
video date 2013 wald mega ereignis war
das war für uns das erste mal dass wir
halt wirklich alleine eigenen song vor
10.000 leuten ist ja nicht ganz wenig
perform des raschen extrem geil dann vor
zwei jahren also das war glaube ich ein
paar monate wohl nachdem wir mit youtube
angefangen hatten hatten wir den web
video preis gewonnen 2012 das war auch
bisher so daten wir 5000 abonnenten und
das war schon eine mega motivation da
war sie schon viele presseleute und so
aufmerksam geworden da hat wird einfach
glück das halt so dass wir dahin wie
gewonnen haben in die rein kam ja das
sind dann eigentlich so die tollsten
momente von familie aus gesehen und und
so die tollsten schönsten momente finde
ich jetzt persönlich auch wenn man
einfach mit anderen youtuber die man
kennenlernt einfach zeit verbringt so
also zum beispiel jetzt es gibt es gibt
ja über diese sommer oder winter camp
von media kraft zum beispiel ist und das
sind ja auch tritt trifft er doch ganz
viele andere youtuber die man so mit dem
man ganz auf scribd oder so das schreibt
und dann die weiter auf einem im
reallife dann zu treffen mit denen das
unternehmen ist auch immer megatoll also
das macht etwas spaß
ich kann das wasser halb besagen nämlich
zu bestätigen und also ich bin auch der
video day 2013 das war also so emrich
das war ein toller moment in dem sinne
einfach weil so unser eigener song mit
dem ihr auch schon recht großen erfolg
erzielt haben mit unserem vermieter
nicht vor 10.000 leuten fast aufgetreten
und das war einfach zweite recht krass
ist einfach ein tolles gefühl und der
tag war zwar total stressig für uns war
wie total viel um die ohren halten aber
28 es war lustig ist weiter so geil es
hat einfach richtig spaß gemacht und das
ist so ein moment den wittmann und dem
wird man noch nicht so schnell vergessen
ich meinen betrieb schon einfach mal vor
ein paar tausend leuten auf das war
schön
also das war auf jeden fall richtig geil
muss man schon sagen was ist das für ein
gefühl was das für ein gefühl es ist auf
jeden fall
es bleibt zu sagen normalerweise wenn
ihr kein mikrofon haben das ist die alte
regel bleibt ware bei rede die immer
residenz ohne sich das wort aber er denn
nun quasi eine dauerhafte battle obwohl
ihr euch super versteht ja frage was uns
besonders war
ich glaube die frage wie lässt sich
selbst beantworten mehrwert die anderen
leute wer das nicht selber erlebt hat
auf so einer bühne der kann das nicht
nachvollziehen was ist das für ein
gefühl ist das ist auf jeden fall die
geburt schafft weihnachten ostern
zusammen also die sache man also die
sache war schon man sieht das publikum
man eigentlich gar nicht beim auftritt
das war alles dunkel fast also ein
bisschen amazon gesehen aber halt
einfach die resonanz man hat ja dann man
man hat sozusagen und sieht man sieht ja
sozusagen auch die leute die deine
videos gucken vor vor den augen und wenn
ihr dann ja auch applaudieren dann fühlt
man sich auch ein bisschen denn dann
fühlt sich das ein bisschen bestätigt
anja der song ist so wie es aussieht gut
angekommen und auch so ist es einfach
ist einfach cool dass also sein seine
musik vor anderen zu zeigen und dann
wenn es so viele sind es ist einfach
geil einfach geil
wieso riesen boxen in der in der
lanxess-arena ich meine dass das ist
einfach das kann man kann ich nicht
beschreiben ist einfach unbeschreiblich
bundes schreibt ist geil
mehr kann ich dazu sagen also noch
mancher ist speziell spezifisch durch
den auftritt war an also anfang wie wir
das mal fühlten weil du stattfinde
gefragt wie weit werden es hier zusammen
mit zwei kollegen in der mitte regnet
dann also mag uns wenn es dem einen
anriss und der band über die kanäle von
rage bringt ist ja so roboter hinauf und
die und dann noch die tanzgruppen die
ganze tänzer und wir hatten das nur ein
einziges mal als richtig geprobt werden
schon mehrmals geprobt aber irgendwie
waren wir zielgenau sicher und dann fünf
minuten vorm auftritt hatte sie wieder
mal kurz durch gegangen waren und selbst
allem sicher und wir waren halt echt so
wirklich ängstlich und das krasseste war
wir hatten wir wussten also wie wir uns
alle bewegen und durch das wissen noch
was doch fast keiner hinter der gene
wien überwiesen
hinter der bühne beim videodreh also die
musik in schondra durchschnitt online
und das war ja erst so dass so erst nach
ein paar sekunden sie wieder auf die
bühne gelaufen und liefert also wieder
hatten also ich kann von einem roman von
andern und er hatte schon mikro in der
hand ich noch keine chance und die musik
die hat angefangen zu laufen und stach
dem mikro in der hand ich muss jetzt
raus raus und dann bin ich irgendwie
hinter der bühne solar um gesprintet so
gelaufen wie ich habe einfach ein mikro
es kommt es auch von anderen apps auf
stefanie kuhn gestoppt und darauf
geachtet das ging also eine sekunde zu
spät und das wäre dann wieder front also
das wäre das amedia glück denn dann
hätte ich zuerst auf die bühne gehen
müssen weil ich ja ich war am anfang
aber durchgehend online die western
reingekommen aber es wäre ich total nass
wäre krass wenn du da wenn du kein mikro
hättest dann aber wieder etwas glück
gehabt also hat er gefragt hat ja
funktioniert so ja und dann wohl auf der
bühne waren es war extrem erleichtert so
weil man dachte so ja die proben also
wohl auch gemerkt haben jetzt läuft also
wir dass willy mitsche texthänger so
oder so haben und damit auch gedacht so
also bei mir war's aber ich hatte habe
mich erleichtert gefühlt weil nur so man
hat vor dem auftritt immer englisch ist
aber beim auftritt war es zumindest bei
mir sondern bei den anderen abgesagt
der auftritt an sich der war eigentlich
total der war eigentlich total cool also
es hat sich also cool im sinne von das
jetzt nicht total aufgeregt war es hat
man man hat es einfach gemacht und das
war so beim videodreh das ist dann
irgendwie beim auftritt wir heimlich in
die hose gemacht habe
das vaterland mitte geteilt und ist doch
cool tasche und mehr kann ich kann ich
kann endlich kann ich dazu nicht sagen
jetzt habt ihr so wahnsinnig viel erlebt
sondern auch wahnsinnig viel geredet
viel geredet war sie viel erlebt
die werbung habe jetzt 400.000 oder was
oder als 60 millionen alben
wie geht es weiter die g 20 jahre
zukommt wie weit er sie werden auf jeden
fall weiter youtube machen ist glaube
ich nicht auszuschließen
wir werden auf jeden fall erstmal sagt
fachabi machen oder also schön abschluss
ist auch ziemlich wichtig eine chance
sind wieder geplant auf jeden fall auch
mit musik video und alles wider
wir haben bald ein paar live auftritte
und merchandise wird auch bei online
geben wahrscheinlich aber auf jeden fall
eigentlich songs die kommen meistens
auch immer extrem gut an und wir dann
auf jeden fall wieder die nächste zeit
welche raushauen
und ja wir wollen einfach weitermachen
wir wollen noch größer werden und
einfach noch weiter machen spaß werden
wir ganz sicher nicht verlieren bin ich
ganz sicher nicht auch leidenschaft und
da verliert man nicht einfach mal den
spaß daran und genau wir wollen
weitermachen
das war nicht der grund warum habe
gleich angefangen
die sache war es erst sein erstes land
will werfer das war die erste parodie
die parodie aber die war also wie weit
auch nicht so reiste von besten da
trotzdem haben irgendwie alle gewonnen
beim webvideo preis ich weiß nicht wie
und warum aber egal aber war der anfang
macht der anleihe haben es ist einfach
so dass wenn man so in einem gewissen
alter ist
zudem wir haben zu dem alter wo man halt
mit youtube angefangen haben war es
etwas so dass man einfach so ins
internet hineinwächst mann entdeckt ist
ja auch immer mehr und wir haben da hat
man auch irgendwann youtube entdeckt und
videos von anderen youtuber nur der
allgemein einfach youtube portal das war
ja früher noch gar nicht so geheim wie
jetzt mittlerweile und dann hat man sich
einfach gedacht ja das will ich aber
gern machen und wir waren schon relativ
also relativ hatten beide gerne mal
irgendwie zu zweit etwas musikalisches
oder so gemacht
also was kreatives ja wenn man zu nennen
kann war einfach was irgendwie ja sowas
in der art
und ja wir haben ja vor allem am anfang
mit musik also parodien und also es war
so es war so wir haben auch so lange vor
youtube.com micro lange beine von
youtube haben wir schon musik sozusagen
zusammengewachsen also haben wir so eine
musik gemacht aber jetzt nicht irgendwie
ernst sagt oder so also das verfahren
und hatten dann irgendwie in der schule
außer ein paar auftritte aber es hat
sich alles aufgebaut also es war eine
gruppe während die anfänger und youtube
wahre alter mit keine gelegenheit aus
seine kreativität oder seine das also
wer seine kreativität hat auch irgendwie
anders zu zeigen und wir haben einfach
angefangen bei ihr weil wir es wollten
weil wir einfach wir wollten ein erstes
vollbeschäftigung sorgen
außerdem finden wir es immer noch
wahnsinnig interessant und langeweile
auch also was ist also viele sagen ja
ich habe mir das lange weile kanal
geschnappt habe ich
angefangen so war sie sich unbedingt
weil er hat jetzt keine langeweile haben
wir wollen ist einfach machen einfach
weil es total interessant fördern weil
es auch spaß gemacht hat und weil man es
so den leuten präsentiert konnte und
weil wir es auch machen wollten wir
haben man nun hat man wechselt sozusagen
das sollte es jetzt in unserem alter
oder in der generation also in der welt
der online generation also ich sehe
heutzutage so viele und unser weiter die
youtube videos machen ist also die
generation und jetzt geht's erst richtig
los glaube ich und es gibt ja jetzt
schon wahnsinnig viele youtuber in allen
altersklassen
also noch mal ganz kurz wie es genau
angefangen hat im großen ganzen haben
uns eigentlich einfach einen camcorder
canon camcorder digitale ja wir haben
uns einfach eine digitalkamera von
unseren eltern geschnappt haben dann ein
paar 10 aufgenommen
und da kam dann irgendwie es erste video
bei raus du bist irgendwie
zusammengekettet mit was ich hab's mit
magix geschichten da wir ja okay kann
man das nachsehen
online ist das allererste video video
es war das erste mal als ich das video
hochgeladen habe war das schon ein jahr
alt ist hatte ich zweifel rechnet also
irgendwas hochladen mit 0 abonnenten 0
klick sondern weil irgendwas machen dass
eine webcam video tutorial wie ich ein
glas milch einen schenkel aber ich habe
ich dann noch gefehlt das wollte ich
extra games oder extrem hohe stimme und
das war schon online ja ja das ist auch
eine online gelassen einfach weiter
seien eigentlich jetzt total peinlich
aber es so einfach krass also es ist
einfach linken wir jetzt mal an dieser
stelle gerne dazu ein drittel
egal aber ist wurde die stimme war
extrem also was ist extrem hoch
ich glaube da reicht 10 oder so noch
hässlicher als jetzt das war unser
erstes video erstes richtiges video war
unsere parodie zu tun und zum schluss
habe ich nur noch eine frage warum habt
ihr drei playstations
ich hoffe ich kann es gut erklären
diesen playstations wir haben wirklich
wir uns zwei geschenkt bekommen
aber die wollen wir nicht verkaufen aus
dem grund da sehr harte gehabt zwei
geschenke oder praxis in hessen regnet
springs so dass wir irgendwie verwöhnte
paulson kinder sind das ist es wirklich
nicht so ich glaube das war damals so
also man kann sich mit you tube
so ist ein ziel der rtl geheimnis mehr 3
playstation ist das hat etwas zu tun
weil eigentlich hat jeder seine eigene
playstation und die dritte die haben die
geschenke also jeder hat eine frühere
eigene zimmer noch eigene heimat aber
trotzdem ihr habt hier die
zusammengestellt ihr habt aus dem grund
weil wir früher war es noch jeder hatte
jeder hat seine eigene playstation war
wir jetzt zusammen noch gezockt haben
und jetzt wo wir hier wurde oder
allgemein jetzt ist habe ich nicht mehr
so dass wir ihn ab dem gezogen und jetzt
haben wir eine gemeinsame playstation
die wir aktiv benutzen und die anderen
ich stehe halt noch jung aber die kamera
nicht mehr verkaufen oder verschenken im
großen im großen ganzen etwas etwas
sodass wir
jeder einzelne playstation hatten und es
in unserem einen einzelnen zimmer hat
zum zocken und die andere hat wird noch
so rum stehen und wo wir mit so einer
art lache zimmer und da steht jetzt also
da steht eigentlich noch da ist halt
dieser andere playstation wenn ihm die
freunde mit und zwar überall oder so da
wird das wenn ich die ganze die
playstation von zimmer zu zimmer tun
aber das hätte hier alle 30
das ist normalerweise nicht dahinter
steht nach 10.30 uhr unsere haben radler
jetzt aber die sache ist einfach wir
hatten vor ein paar tagen waren paar
kollegen burns und wir haben dann ein
bisschen halt gezockt die ganz nach
wunsch
und da passiert so was schon das 3 ps
preis in einem zimmer stehen und erst
wenn man zu faul das wieder zurück sowas
bei raus weil wir haben jetzt mittel
erklärungen schritten playstation über
plötzliche gilt als wort playstation kam
mit 20 mal vor so nicht es wird sonnig
damit wäre diese frage auch cap vielen
dank und vielen dank
danke für das interview und spaß wieder
was erfahren